when Paris is best known shopping
Emporium unveils its Christmas window
display
it's a grand event the Bulova house
Monde is blocked for traffic and French
actress Lea Seydoux pushes the button to
launch the lights
afterwards she heads over to admire the
window displays accompanied by the press
and scores of visitors after all the
animated window displays are a must-see
and a Paris traditionally there's a new
star guest every year and because it all
happens on the street we can all take
part without an invitation we come with
our family every year to admire the
displays it's like a Christmas movie
every year this year five of the twelve
windows are devoted to the Beauty and
the Beast fairytale the scenes are
promoting the feature film starring lay
us they do set to open next February but
isn't it a bit early for a Christmas
display for Frederick Laveau the visual
identity director at Galilee Lafayette
that's not a problem he's already in the
festive spirit in January
blendin on pathology we need almost a
year to get ready this time we developed
a concept that would appeal to children
first we sketched out the scenes and
then we decided what colors and
materials to use and which suppliers we
would order from it purely hosiah
maturely cool elephant sir the new
display windows do have plenty of kid
appeal they tell the story of Lily the
doll and Martin the teddy bear on their
journey of adventure outfitted by star
designer Marc Jacobs nuvvu Ewan petite
fille I'm petite we had this cheeky
little girl with Tufte hair of course
she had to have a friend who was funny
and cute a cuddly teddy bear we want to
appeal to the whole family because
people come here to do shopping for the
whole family who visit schweden when the
figures were made in this studio in a
suburb of Paris they were designed by a
puppet maker and have mechanically
moving parts the lavish decorations were
a labor of love for their maker setting
them up however can be a challenge
Zebedee pesky fools some of them are two
and a half by three meters after making
them in the studio we took them apart
for transportation and reassemble them
in the display window plus every
mechanism has to work properly the
strings on the marionettes might tear or
there might be a short circuit it's a
race against time difficult little and
there's a race among Europe's
traditional department stores each year
to see who can come up with the biggest
and brightest Christmas decorations and
special promotional events they
increasingly recruit big celebrity names
including fashion designers luxury
shopping Emporium Harrods in London
regularly most top stars in 2005
American actress Lucy Liu and last year
British singer Lily Allen it's
interesting to see what others are doing
but not in the sense that you want to
win or be the best I just want to bring
our message across
I respect the competitions and obviously
I like to see what other stores are
doing buddy well whether theirs is the
best remains to be seen but together Lee
Lafayette are definitely the first to
unveil a Christmas window display
earlier every year it's pretty funny but
I guess it puts you in the holiday mood
I'm impressed and I would advise
everyone to come and see it it's free
it's beautiful and you can see how much
work went into it the race for the most
elaborate Christmas window display is
officially on here in Paris Fedele Lulu
is glad to have his big day behind him
but it's just I'm not going to say what
went wrong but 80% of it worked I think
people are happy personally I'm never
satisfied with my work but that
motivates me to do even better next year
equal basis in the meantime his work
will remain on show at the famous
Parisian store until the 5th of January